a lot of Russians are concerned maybe
not willing to express it publicly
unless they're in the opposition uh how
Russia's growing economic dependence on
China you know that if you read the
statement it's all about this is a
relationship of equals but it looks
increasingly unequal because essentially
the rut the Russian economy is was
already much smaller than that of China
it's under massive sanctions in the west
so
you know from anything from
semiconductors 5G consumer goods they
can't get from the West
they've all got to get it all from China
and that puts XI in in an immensely
powerful position and even if he didn't
exploit it that much now I think it must
make the Russians a little bit nervous
about
how that relationship is going to unfold
because I mean if you're looking really
kind of back into history that as you
know Cindy you know a lot of what is
Russia now was China in the 19th century